when you gave this speech when you won
the Academy Award I think this was maybe
the speech you made when you won from
milk he basically said you know I know
I'm difficult sometimes and I was
wondering like what you were referring
to because to me you're committed guy I
mean if you take on a role you're gonna
[ __ ] put your life into it you're
gonna research the [ __ ] out of it you're
gonna you know you're gonna really live
that role why is it difficult to work
with you why would people in Hollywood
say that yeah there have been struggled
times I've worked with directors who
I've felt might have found a different
job description and and perhaps were
actually weren't the storytellers that
their initial meetings with with each of
us actors might have indicated actors
are kind of Canaries in the coal mine
emotionally and you have to go to you
know whatever place is necessary inside
yourself if you don't have somebody
there who at least respects that most of
what I was referring to is that the
arrogance goes further than charm and I
am aware that that I am it can be a
difficult person to like from afar often
I sometimes think that you know I have a
great love affair with humanity but not
too good about humans let me ask you
been are you a difficult guy to be
married to or in a romantic relationship
with is it always all about Sean is it
always though it's Sean's way or no I
mean are you what is their problem what
is it what is romance something that you
will get right eventually well yeah I
think so why what are you difficult what
if what is it about you that day if I
want I would go out with you I think
you're attractive what would it be hard
for me to be in a relationship I will
say that I'm a person who feels them
that expresses them energetically round
that has misled people to think that I
think it's all about me and and so I
interview you're talking about what
would be with a lady named Leila George
she knows me better than I do on this
level it doesn't mean that I agree with
her perceptions but but I certainly find
them fascinating and
is leyla George your psychotherapist is
she someone that you sought out on this
she say the gal in my life
you